[Music]
all right
recently i have
had a new uh kazoo echo
can you guys hear that that's cute
okay no so to recently these 83
millionaires 83 millionaires from seven
countries
released an open letter to their
governments
and calling for permanent tax increase
on them what yes so they're saying taxes
taxes taxes they don't speak for
themselves
where from what countries seven
different countries oh
okay so i will read this letter to you
as quickly as i can because it's a
little long
huh okay can you do it in an indian
accent i can't
here we go cause i know it's indian one
of those things why is it always indeed
indian millionaire
indian millionaire i know there's indian
millionaire in there so it's titled
millionaires for humanity
sign on letter to our fellow global
citizens as kovan 19 strikes the world
millionaires
like us have a critical role to play in
in healing our world
no we are not the ones caring for the
sick and intense
intensive care awards we are not driving
the ambulances that will bring the ill
to hospitals we are not restock
restocking groceries
store shelves or delivering food
door-to-door but we do have money
lots of it money that is desperately
needed now and will continue to be
needed in the years ahead of us as our
world recovers from this crisis
today we are undersigned millionaires
ask our today we the undersigned
millionaires ask our governments to
raise taxes on people like us
immediately substantially permanently
the impact of this crisis will last for
decades it will push half
a billion more people into poverty
hundreds of millions of people will lose
their jobs as businesses close
some permanently already there are
nearly a billion children out of school
many with no access to the resources
they need to continue
their learning and of course the absence
of hospital beds protective masks and
ventilators
is a painful daily reminder of the
inadequate investment made
in public health system across the world
the problems caused by
and revealed by covet 19 can't be solved
with charity no matter how generous
government leaders must take the
responsibility for raising the funds we
need
and spending them fairly we can ensure
we adequately
fund our health systems schools and
security through a permanent tax
increase
on the wealthiest people on the planet
people like us
we owe a huge debt to the people working
on the front lines of this global battle
most essential workers are grossly
underpaid for the burden they carry
at the vanguard of this fight we are we
are our
health care workers what at the vanguard
of this fight
are our health care workers sorry 70 of
whom are women
they confront the deadly virus each day
at work
while bearing the majority of
responsibility for unpaid work at home
the risks are the risk these brave
people willingly embrace every day in
order to care for the rest of us
requires us to establish a new real
committed commitment to each
other and what into what that really
means
uh our interconnectedness has never been
more clear
we must rebalance our world before it's
too late there will not be another
chance to get this right
unlike tens of millions of people around
the world we do not have to worry about
losing our jobs our homes or
our ability to support our families we
are not fighting
on the front lines of this emergency and
we are much less likely to be its
victims so please
tax us tax us tax us it is the right
choice
it is the only choice humanity is more
important than our money
yeah tax them text them tax them
tax them no that's actually really well
written that was kind of like i don't
know about
taxes also that is a great argument that
also tells me these millionaires
actually trust their government
true because there's a lot of
billionaires that are like don't tax me
because once you take the money away
from the gut from me
once it gets funneled into the
government system who knows who's going
to receive it
because the pentagon lost three trillion
dollars
there's a debt can you imagine how much
money
that is so right before 9 11 there was a
huge
[ __ ] um uh what do you call it like
uh
a committee that was on um review
and they were pushing the pentagon
to disclose how they [ __ ] just lost
three trillion dollars and then 911
happened and it got buried under the rug
so maybe that's why that's what some
people say it's a conspiracy that's what
some people say i'm all for taxes if i
saw our money being spent on social
services
and we don't see that in america
unfortunately there's a lot of
corruption
so taxing the rich might not necessarily
be the best
thing here you know well maybe they come
from a government where the the
government's doing good
seven different countries i don't have a
list of the countries themselves but
for example one of the signers is walt
disney company aerys
heiress abigail disney and also tim
disney and so
they are so a lot of these millionaires
um
it seems to be that they have like
inherited a lot of these
oh it's just rich guilt then trust fund
baby these guys are [ __ ]
trust fund babies not all of them not
all of them i wish i had rich guilt dude
like for example like like ben and
jerry's
like uh they also signed ben and jerry
signing off
no that's jerry it was actually just
jerry who signed it that they included
in this article
uh but yeah and then like four weddings
and a funeral director richard
curtis adventure capitalist william
janeway
um a movie director amy
zeigering i would go after the multi
like the super billionaires and everyone
who's profited off of
um the the hurt of like the people so
for example the sackler family
um they're the ones that basically
created like
oxy and like all the painkillers and
they profited off of so many american
deaths
right and they're just mega [ __ ] rich
and no one knows of them and how much
damage they've done to the
to our people and maybe to some of your
relatives or whatever
they knew like they knew that the drugs
were very harmful
and very addictive but they ended up
doubling the doses because
they wanted to make more sales there's
just all kinds of [ __ ] up [ __ ] like
that and i'm like when it comes to
people like that if we could target them
individually
and tax them for what they've done and
profited off i think that's pretty fair
right but also to just make this blanket
statement of like hey
if you just tax people more then all of
a sudden we can use that money to make
things better
i don't necessarily think that because
man there's just so much corruption in
our government and how they spend and
how they like
it's all about the systems in place yeah
like in california we have some of the
highest taxes
uh in america and we have some of the
most [ __ ] up
everything school system roads and
everything we have the homeless problem
so like definitely more taxes isn't the
answer but having better systems and
figuring out
ways of better accountability yeah
everyone that's the answer
because i think i'm all for more taxes
if i can see
that it's actually being used for
something good
yeah well recently like they got some
huge tax breaks
like the wealthy and the middle class is
really suffering from that
um but this one person named morris
pearl who's the managing director at uh
or he was former managing director at
blackrock which is an investment
managing
company he said uh he's like i'm
wealthier than i was before the pandemic
and i don't even work for a living
uh there are millions of people who
aren't able to earn anything and they
don't have earnings from a stock
portfolio give me money then
right so that's why he's part of the
assignment signer yeah good
yeah when when they say millionaires too
there's a huge
difference between like well i'm
technically
a millionaire but i'm still working on
it like
i i don't have any cash like everything
is built
i own assets right which is like i have
things that generate income but they're
not going into my pocket
they're going right back into paying
people to build my businesses
i'm a beginner millionaire now um
trust fund babies are people who have
old money they have
money that works for with like money is
working
itself right so they're invested in
stocks or whatever they have what's
called
very passive income where every month
they might get a hundred thousand
dollars just in their bank account
because their great great great grandpa
had a
massive orange grove that you know did
really well
so there's such a huge disparity right
like even in california right
technically a lot of people are
millionaires because their homes
are worth a lot valued at a million
dollars and they might have a lot of
things
that if you sell it all they have a
million dollars so
it's difficult to really gauge this i
would say like maybe someone who has
eight figures and above maybe
right it or or can we not just net worth
but how about liquid like what that
means is how about
people who have a lot of cash in their
bank and
they're not doing anything with it that
might be a different way of looking at
it versus just blanket
blanketing like millionaires because
it's a huge
huge difference there's hey i'm taking
uh
private jets everywhere i go
millionaires and then there's
i'm still flying economy but i'm flying
a lot
you know so yeah just
like the system said though like um not
even just like hey why is california
being taxed so hot
but uh you know our systems aren't like
receiving those funds or the positive
growth
growth from it there's also the systems
of like even the taxation right
like there's all these really really
wealthy people that because they're
connected to like the real estate or
commercial real estate industry in some
ways
they can like mitigate their taxes to
the point where they're not paying
anything
yeah they're saying that right that um
so two years ago
there was the massive tax cuts and jobs
act
or yeah massive is is not part of the
title
anyway so that went into effect and
they're saying that
the 400 richest u.s families now pay a
lower
overall tax rate than the middle class
which is the first time
that that's happened in 100 years and so
by comparison
back in 1970 the richest americans paid
more than 50
of their income tax which is twice as
much as working classes
yeah that is true yeah the the um rich
are getting richer during this whole
thing because
i um i don't know you know like a lot of
people
are investing into stocks and all that
then they're you know their values are
going high
because of that but also
man this is so complicated yeah jeff
bezos made like i think like 50 billion
or something just over this thing but
it's also like
it's i also can't like i guess
throw shade at him because i'm like
during this time
we're all also contributing to that you
know like i don't know anyone that
doesn't order anything on amazon
so it's not like he's exploiting people
like we're literally voting him yeah to
be richer
like all of us are we're all
contributing to his wealth growing he's
so convenient
but in the system but in the system that
he can play
in the loopholes he can pretty much uh
abuse his
similar way where he doesn't have to pay
taxes yeah yeah so like everybody
is yeah when you're totally choosing to
to support but at the same time like a
percentage of everything that we even to
even buy something on amazon
i gotta like pay my income tax on that
money to have it be clean to use
you know what i'm saying so for the
person to receive this money if he
doesn't have to pay
proportionate taxes then our system is
yeah it's just not going to work
over time which is based off of exactly
what she just said
if back in the 70s the 400 richest
families were paying 50
of the actual taxes and now they're
paying less than the middle class
we're [ __ ] well i think it even goes
up to
um like people that are within the five
percent because if you think about it
right like
a lot of millionaires don't have the
money and resources
to build a different accounting firm or
even get sources
like offshore accounts what like all
these guys do
is they say should i pay
uh 200 million to the u.s or should i
pay
you know 50 million to this firm and
then move my money offshore
i'm gonna do the 50 million why should i
pay the extra 200 million right so
that's kind of how they're thinking
about
it it's almost like this if you if
you're super rich right
if you're yeah well it is it is it is
it's
a game so like let's say let's say um
you you have a lambo
and you're [ __ ] rich and you know
that you're
you're in a rush right so you you just
drive up and there's no parking you just
[ __ ] say [ __ ] it
i'll just leave my car here because the
ticket's only 40 bucks
versus me wasting my time it's entitled
i'm not saying this is right or wrong
i'm just saying that
that's the perspective that a lot of
people have taxing them
more might not also be the solution
because here's the thing
he's like all right i'm gonna send my
money offshore because i
it's 50 mil compared to paying taxes to
america for 200 mil
he goes okay well guess what
i might move my whole company offshore
and then i'm a i'm a i'm under foreign
district uh
uh jurisdiction jurisdiction so don't
even pay the 50 million
at all now but america can't can't
control
if you sell to the country because
unless
you're like north korea and there's this
crazy trade or whatever right
technically we're a free trade like this
country's
like you could you could do it they
can't say oh your products you bought it
from amazon
so now you're gonna get taxed 20 times
more to make this fair
so that's where the complication comes
down because
it's it's almost like this if the
governments don't bend
then they're gonna completely leave out
of america
and then they're not gonna be you know
making but they can still sell to
america so it's kind of this weird
catch-22 yeah hello guys thank you guys
so much for watching
all of our videos and i know it's been a
million years in the making but we
finally got
just kidding news merch yep so make sure
you go down to the store below
and you can bring around wow yeah you
can get a
jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
huh